Let's discuss the solution for the second performance
comparison quiz. Now the laptop that we had took
10 minutes, and the new one takes 4
hours because we are actually using the old laptop
to do this. The speedup is equal to
the latency of the previous thing, which is 10
minutes, divided by the latency of the new
thing we're using which is 240, so this time
the speedup is 0.04. So the correct answer
here is 0.04. Again, if there is an actual
slowdown from the previous thing to the new thing
we are using, then we can expect the speedup
to be lower than 1. And if got instead
of 24 as our answer, that should mean that
whatever we are using now is faster than before.
So that should tell us that something is wrong.
So pretty much, by kind of checking if it makes sense,
you know, is the new thing actually having a speedup as opposed
to slow down? If it is a speedup it should be
above 1, a speedup lower than 1 is an actual slow down.